على مواقع التواصل تجد الكثير من الشباب
والشابات الذين يقدمون محتوى خاص بالسفا
المنفرد سولو منهم ضيفتنا الشابه هيفاء
بسيسو والتي تقدم وتشارك دائما تجاربها في
مختلف البلاد التي تزور منذ انطلاقتها حتى
اليوم تحرس هيفا على كسر الصور النمطيه
للفتاه العربيه كما تشارك جمهورها في كثير
من القضايا الثقافيه المختلفه بدات
مسيرتها في مجال الاعلام ومن ثم انتقلت
الى انشاء قناه على اليوتيوب وهذه القناه
تحتسب فلايد هيفاء او حلق مع هيفاء ومن
خلال اصبحت تهدف الى تشجيع الافراد لخلق
تغيير في حياتهم
[موسيقى]
مدونه سفر هيفاء بسيعد صباحك نورتنا بصباح
العربيه اهلا صباح الخير
اليوم اهلا بك طيب هيفاء السفر منفرد بيت
الظهيره 2023
يحب ان يسافر بمفرده باعتقادك لماذا
يمكن لانه كتير ناس مو شرط بدهم يستنوا
ناس ثانيين ليجمعهم بالرحله
ووو وبحث كثير نعصر عندهم فضول يكتشفوا
حالهم من خلال السفر انا دايما بحكي انه
بسافر مش بس اني اكتشف همم لا تغرف او سور
الصين العظيم بسافر لاكتشف حالي والبلدي
اللي راحه فيها فلما الواحد يسافر لحاله
بيكون في شويه حريه اكثر
مربوط بتجارب ومربوط بالذكريات وصور ذهنيه
هيك بذكرتنا طول العمر ما بتحبي انه
تشاركيها مع حدا بتقول لي تتذكري لما كنا
هون تتذكر لما كنا هون مثلا هلا الشيء
الحلو بالموضوع انه الواحد لما يسافر
لحاله بحس بيصير عنده كثير اصحاب
طويله صفره للشهرين بمفردك في امريكا
الوسطى زرتي مختلف الدول الم تملي يعني
كيف كانت تجربه بالاول شهرين لحالك اه لا
صراحه كل يوم مغامره كثير كبيره كل يوم
اتعرف على ناس كثير
ولما اتعرف على ناس هناك مع بعض بنروح على
اماكن ثانيه همم بس مش بطريقه انه مش
عقلانيه او خطيره لا يعني الواحد همم يعني
بتبع حدث وببين على الواحد انا بحس حالي
دائما الله حاميني وبتعرف على ناس بتجنن
مين بعده يصورك هالانس ستوري سوريا
ااا بدخلوا بالجو معي في شات واحده لقيتها
بالبحر جنبي قلت لها معلش تساعديني وبعدين
لما اقول لهم انه عمل الانستغرام او بلوجر
كثير بتحمسوا معي ما بعرف ليش ههه
انه ما تاخذي صدقاتك بتعرفيها بس تتعرفي
على ناس جداد هلا حلو الواحد يسافر مع ناس
بيعرفهم انا سافرت كمان واحده متسفرات مع
اهلي وعرفنا بعض بلفل ثاني مختلف تماما
يعني رحنا شيء وروحنا شيء ثاني انا السفر
بالنسبه لي هيك ومشاكل يعني
بس الباقي كله مع بعض همم بس الواحد لما
يكون لحاله بيصير المجال مفتوح اكثر لناس
يحكوا معه يتقربوا لعنده همم
وانا برايي يعني ما بسافر خالص انا بسافر
بيجننوا في شيء نتعلم ومن اي حدا بنقابله
وفعلا يعني انا مسافرات صار لي شيء سبع
سنين بسافر ما صار معي موقف خطير او حدا
ضايقني او شيء هيك طيب هيفا انت شو
اكتشفتي بذاتك من خلال السفر يعني من خلال
الايام الطويله والليالي اللي قعدتيها مع
حالك وتفكري شو حسيتي في شغله هيك ما كنت
عرفتيها عن نفسك هذا احلى سؤال على قلبي
كثير لانه دائما بحكي السفر حول العالم
والسفر للعالم الداخلي
همم
السفر كتير بيغير يعني كثير بيغير
بالشخصيه بالمفاهيم
قد ما بيغير
والشجاعه انه الواحد يكون عنده القابليه
يحكي باي باي للشخصيه اللي قبل اللي كان
بيعرفها ما يتمسك كثير بالايجو
اللي اعطاني هالسفر ثانيه
كثير كمان عشت مع اللوكرز يعني رحت على
افريقيا عيشه بالفلين
اللي هناك رحت كوستاريكا عشت في الغابه
كيف بطبخوا بالغابه كيف بيعملوا اشياء
بالغابه وقعدت مع الكبار بالسن اللي
بالسنتريلامريكا بالمكسيك كيف بيصلوا مع
بعض
الصغار والمراهقين وكيف بيحكوا مع بعض كيف
الاطفال بيحترموا الكبار